brad i always love talking to you in
fact um i i want to show my audience now
this is a wonderful painting uh george
has bragged about it now that you guys
are
in quarantine this is actually a
painting that george does this hang over
your bed or uh this painting no it's in
the bedroom
it's in the bedroom it is a painting of
brad when he was young
and when he was a runner he was like a
thoroughbred if you uh remember
and uh he looks fantastic he has a full
boner
it's it's it's really it's bred with an
erection
and the waistline look at that
that is the cast there is the famous
painting that
george commissioned by an artist uh brad
uh standing there
nude who is that and that's me up up
there
on the wall black my photo of george
running yes
uh yes what a painting that is and uh
brad
i know you say in the painting you're
not erect but my goodness uh you're semi
correct are you not
you you might have noticed he's turned
his
waist around so that you don't quite see
the important part this painting
did you pose or did you give them a
photograph and they painted it
you posed he posed he posed and you
stood there for how many hours because
the painting's quite elaborate i mean
it's quite realistic
it's like every every afternoon for a
week i think because uh brad was in such
an incredible shape george were you
present for the painting were you
nervous that the artist might even
seduce brad
if no the artist was a friend
and i trusted him implicitly completely
totally and when he didn't raise my body
though he was killing me oh you have a
wonderful body
brad you were in that kind of shape i
mean george george
you could not get enough of bread is it
true absolutely and
i was ravenous george was a hot guy too
that's another thing you don't
understand
george was a hot man in those years i
mean he's oh i know he knows
i saw him in that star trek episode
where he had his shirt off
and he was remember he had a fever and
he was dueling everyone with those
swords
he was magnificent i mean let's be
honest the two of you a power couple
extraordinaire